when facing the unknown Panic is the
first automatic human response then
comes acceptance then comes adaptation
then comes cooperation in the face of
danger our brain switches to panic mode
and we become even more irrational than
we already are but why can't we escape
this mental prison the answer to this
question lies in the periphery of one's
Consciousness we live aimlessly breathe
mechanically and
acting the surging flux of the present
tense we forget to breathe properly and
act as rational agents instead of
primitive egocentric beings we can adapt
to new realities faster and better than
we actually expect Carl Sagan once wrote
in the course of looking deeply within
ourselves we may challenge Notions that
give Comfort before the Terrors of the
world let us challenge these Notions now
let's move to caring a bit faster than
usual we are in this together and we can
face the unknown together